hi there I'm Yasmin I'm the community
manager here at sandbox interactive and
I'm going to be talking about Albion
online classes character customization
system today so in most games of the MMO
genre when players choose a character
they also choose a class to play with
that character and that essentially
determines their playstyle to the rest
of the game then I'll be an online we
didn't want to do this we wanted to give
players complete flexibility over how
they play it and what they choose is
their play style so for this reason we
gave players a lot of choice and how
they kid to their characters up and I'm
just going to demonstrate that to you
now in the game so an Albion online our
motto has always been you are what you
were and as you can see on this
character at the moment what I'm wearing
is a set of heavy play armor and a sword
in the shield so this is essentially the
normal load out of a traditional tank
class character so I could probably tank
pretty effectively with this and this is
sort of what we want people to do we
want to allow players to choose the
traditional classes of an MMO genre but
we also want them to experiment so for
instance I could also pop on a major
staff and a spell tomb which will also
give me buffs my mana and this is
perfectly acceptable and I'll be online
we want players to be able to experiment
with that and kind of combine different
aspects of different classes in order to
create their perfect character another
thing I could pop on is a crossbow and
run around with that to do some more
kind of ranged moves with my plate armor
on or I could pop on the traditional
garb of a mage also pop back on my sword
and my shield so yeah we really do want
players to kind of fiddle around with
the different combinations and kind of
just see what works best for them and
each different combination will have its
own strengths and weaknesses so there
won't be one perfect one to use
we just want players to be able to kind
of experiment and kind of see yeah what
works for them and what they think is
best
so another source of variety and Albion
online is this series of spells that we
have to offer so in the game all items
are player crafted and when players
craft these items they can choose on the
series of spells and ability to use the
craft onto these items ok so I'm just
going to show you that now in the game
so I'm gonna head over to this Forge
here and just click on him and as you
can see that brings up a menu giving me
a couple of things that I can craft so
I'm gonna craft some weapons now so I'm
going to go first of all for an axe and
now we want this to be quite a kind of
close quarters combat damage oriented
weapons so you'll be able to see that
from the different spells that we have
to equip onto it so in these top two
slots we'll have active spells that we
can pop on there and a one slot for a
spotter for a passive spell down here so
if I click on these this game still is
an alpha so please excuse the kind of
early Y that we have here but as you can
see from these all of these spells are
quite damage oriented to kind of fit
with that weapon so I'm gonna go for
decapitate and I think Ren which is a
damage over time spell just kind of yeah
really make that quite a damage oriented
weapon and again you can combine any of
those faults together and then these
kind of give me different buffs to my
auto attack so I've got chance of
increased movement speeds or healing or
just buff to my damage with auto attack
I'm gonna go again for that one just to
really kind of unify these spells here
and craft that one and that should equip
automatically because I currently have
nothing in my main hand so yeah there we
go that's equipped immediately and as
you can see now that I've got it
equipped I have these two spells that I
the active ones up here ready for me to
use because I've got that I quit
currently in contrast if I go for a tier
3 broadsword and this is a bit more of a
tactical weapon and still close combat
melee and still kind of two active
spells at the top here and one slot for
a passive spell but as you can see if I
click on here we have a little bit more
of an array of different supposed to go
for
so the idea is that you kind of combine
different ones of these two kind of to
create the sort of perfect weapon in
different situations so for instance if
I were in a PvE fight for instance I
might want to go for a kind of defensive
stance and taunt just against mods it
might be a good combination to go for
and then perhaps restoring some energy
with each Auto Attack and in contrast if
I were in a PVE pvp rather against
perhaps arranged opponent I might want
to go for a dash and a hamstring and so
kind of a dash will bring me in for sort
of close quarters melee and the
hamstring will stop them from being able
to run away by reducing their movement
speed and then again I can go for and
increase also attack damage to power off
that one and I'll equip that one quickly
and then I'll be able to show you but
again I have this in my main hand now I
then have the two spells - and hamstring
up they're just available to me now that
I've equipped this sword and again this
system of spells and applies to all
different items in the game so it's not
just weapons it's also armor and again
we really just want players just as with
the all the items themselves to be able
to kind of experiment and combine
different spells on different items to
create really create their perfect
loadout and they're perfect
an ideal weapon for different situations
so that was your deaf blog about Albion
online classes character customization
system I hope you enjoyed and we'll see
you next time